un match pour se rapprocher du haut du
classement poissy recevez les joueurs de
chartres coachée par jean pierre papin
l'occasion de la 12e journée de
nationale 2 poussés par leurs supporters
les pisciacais enchaîne les offensives
et trouve la faille à la 21e minute par
samba dème dès les 1 à 0 et poissy se
relâchent et se fait rejoindre au score
juste avant la pause par chartres un
partout à la mi-temps on a fait une
première mi temps un peu un peu calmé on
n'était pas à 100 % juste après le
premier but on a commencé à un peu
reculé chose qu'on n'a pas l'habitude de
faire
au retour des vestiaires les deux
équipes veulent prendre l'ascendant le
match est rythmé mais aucune ne
parviendra à marquer ce second but score
final un but partout la preuve en est
revenu en deuxième mi-temps bien
meilleur avec beaucoup plus d'envié et
là on a su avoir beaucoup plus
d'occasions malheureusement ça n'a pas
plus finir c'était pas ça parce qu'en
face il ya une très très belle équipe il
ya beaucoup de vitesse et je pense qu'on
a bien géré la deuxième mi temps on est
un petit peu déçu à 12 mi-temps mais bon
je pense que faut savoir se satisfaire
de pas grand chose au classement poissy
8e de national 2 et pointe désormais à
cinq points du podium prochain match
pour les yvelinois 8e tour de coupe de
france ce dimanche 28 novembre sur la
pelouse de versailles